welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode three long long time this
emotional episode titled after the 1970
Linda Ronstadt song that breaks our
hearts again and hopefully now get some
stranger things running up that hill
treatment I'm gonna break down why this
song was especially perfect giving
Frank's song code and just so many other
interesting details that you might have
missed from this episode this is exactly
the kind of thing that I love to break
down because it's not like we're looking
for Easter eggs it's just like little
interesting choices in the writing and
the acting and the directing that make
this such a rewarding storytelling
experience and thank you to boxu for
sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later and a reminder to
please subscribe to new Rockstar's new
channel the Deep dive launching February
17th because if you'd like me breaking
down more intimate stories to deeper
themes Beyond comic books video game
Easter eggs I got an emotional wallet
coming your way with the Deep dive of
everything everywhere all at once okay
last episode of The Last of Us started
and ended with an oral transmission of
the quarter steps fungus a kiss of death
for test that serves as a grim
reflection of the writer's theme of the
day danger of love and the opening
credits Echo that with a vision of a
human face mouth open formed by this
fungus Joel's Knuckles are still bloody
from beating that soldier in episode 1.
despite him telling Tess at the top of
last episode that it would heal quickly
we see him stacking rocks which some
hikers do to Mark Trails some to
practice mindfulness but is also some
ancient culture's way of marking Graves
so right now this is the best Joel can
really do to give Tess a funeral because
Joel and Ellie are still not really able
to communicate about it look I've been
thinking about I want your sorry I
wasn't gonna say I'm sorry I was gonna
say that I've been thinking about what
happened
nobody made you a test take me yeah it's
interesting Joel doesn't really know
Ellie as well as he assumes he does Alex
way more pissed off at Joel she's
blaming him for Tess's death Ellie asks
about the scar on Joel's head someone
shot at me and missed see that's cool
is she back
yeah
no I missed two it happens more often
than you think now actually in the game
Joel has a scar on the bridge of his
nose which is a very subtle detail from
the night Sarah was shot he doesn't have
a scar on his nose before but he
actually incurs this injury during this
attack and is to carry this reminder of
his daughter's death with him on his
face from here forward but in the show I
assume this scar on his cheek is from
some other incident he definitely didn't
have it in that 2010 garden party that
it had with Phil and Frank so the sign
in front of the Cumberland Farms has had
a few letters drop and I want to say the
top word was children in the beneath
something about rations maybe I don't
know maybe with the Panic overflower
rations were only given to families with
children in those few days inside Ellie
finds a Mortal Kombat 2 game box never
play this one
all right a friend who knew everything
about this game this is one character
named Molina who takes off her mask and
she has monster teeth and then she
swallows you whole and Barks out your
bones she's referring to Molina's
fatality move which of course was the
kiss of death a kiss of death is also
how the cordyceps is transmitted Ellie
asks is there anything bad in here just
you ah getting funnier yeah Joel's
making a call back to last episode in
the Super Cuts there's not gonna be
anything bad in here just you oh funny
it's a bit of a dad joke but it's also a
lesson from Joel the natural threats we
Face are unfeeling and amoral it's only
really Humanity that has the capacity
for Evil Ellie finds a box of tampons
and this half-buried stalker now just a
reminder Runners are the early stages of
the infected stalkers are the half
mushroom-headed because we're under a
year of infected and then beyond that
are the clickers they're in the blind
fully covered heads who are over a year
of being affected we will meet stages
beyond that as we go but I love this
shot this close-up we can really see the
prosthetic makeup from Pat food who also
worked on Chernobyl House of the dragon
and stranger things it just makes this
fungal outgrowth look even more Vivid
than the clickers are from a distance
this is gross but you could see beads of
pus on the cheek and then chunks of
Flesh on the stalks that are growing out
of the head that yellow infected eye
continues to follow Ali's knife so for
now the fungus is still puppeting the
host optic nerve but Ellie is testing to
see if there is a soul inside recalling
her question last week to Joel is it
hard
like knowing they were people once
sometimes Joel stashes his rifle not
much ammo out there for this thing
mostly useless oh you're just gonna
leave it there
no solid practical logic here as in the
gameplay if your weapon runs out of ammo
it's useless
and for Joel's case here it would be
extra weight and something he could lose
that might be weaponized against him in
the future Ellie asks how the infection
started how did it even start if you
have to get bit to be infected then who
bit the first person
was it a monkey I bet it was a monkey
yeah I love this because it's kind of a
reference to the movie 28 Days Later
where the outbreak came from infected
chimps and that movie came out in June
2003 and would have been the most recent
major zombie movie before outbreak day
so naturally there would be some monkey
theory that would have made it into the
urban myths that Ellie knows and Joel
further confirms the flower theory that
I discussed back in week one it's only
got into the food supply probably a
basic ingredient like flour sugar bread
cereal
pancake mix now I thought Joel was
joking around about being on Atkins but
if he really was avoiding carbs that
would explain why he didn't get infected
and yes that paws on pancake mix does
remembering Sarah trying to make him
Pancakes on his birthday they passed a
mass grave of people that fedra force
evacs and then killed when there wasn't
enough room in a qz we Linger on the
remains of a parent and their child
reigned with Joel the parent figure with
Ellie the child figure in the background
now this is incredibly morbid but
artistically I really appreciate the
transition on the clothes this family
was last wearing flashing back 20 years
earlier this Mass grave is a fate far
worse than any of the infected if you
ask me who one could argue were
overtaken by nature to grow into
something monstrous but also somewhat
beautiful meet Bill Nick Offerman who
watches all this going down from his
survivalist basement not today you knew
order Jack boot folks New World Order
was a globalist conspiracy theory that
grew in popularity during the 90s and
early 2000s an idea that someone like
Bill would totally ascribe to Bill's
computer uses Windows 2000 even though
Windows XP would have totally been
around in 2003 just makes sense that
bill wouldn't want to upgrade the OS
because that's how they track you also
his guns and ammo magazine is actually
the issue from earlier the year February
2003. the fedra Evac notice was put in
front of the town's civil war memorial
statue of Abraham Lincoln another
example of how all of U.S history all of
human history was overshadowed by this
apocalyptic event Bill's bunker includes
guns gun magazines sulfuric acid and the
like but as he rises to the ground level
right away we see a surprisingly stocked
wine rack just an early sign that bill
has somewhat more culture taste than
you'd expect from a stereotypical
survivalist at the gas station Bill
punches the highest grade of fuel
because who cares though notice it still
only brings up to a dollar 19 per gallon
oh my God 2003. he loots a Home Depot a
scene that feels like the reason Nick
Offerman was cast in this role after he
played Ron Swanson on Parks and Rec hi
there is there a project you're working
on I know more than you
all right but while Ron probably would
have looted some Scotch from the liquor
store Bill loot some Kamas cabernet from
Napa Valley this town is a white church
in the background which in the games is
where Bill holds up as his home but in
the show he stays in the house this
episode gives Bill and Frank a happier
relationship unlike the game where by
the time Joel and Ellie catch up with
Bill Frank is already dead and it was
implied they ended on bitter terms had
the show versions of Bill and Frank
follow that path maybe bill would have
continued to follow his more paranoid
Tendencies ended up in the church four
years after this bill listens to cream's
white room which is a song about an
empty apartment because despite Bill
building this Fortress his home is still
empty Bill's basement has some bathers
up Don't Tread on Me Join or Die Joyner
die with Benjamin Franklin's political
cartoon encouraging the American
colonies to unite against the British
which is ironic for a loner like Bill
but exactly the mindset he'll be
following by joining with Frank he can
either connect with another human or Die
Alone Now notice that bill is actually
welding something this is the modded Bud
saw with the pie that we later see in
action when the Raiders attack the buzz
saw releases the Sparks and those Sparks
ignite the gas that blows out the pipe
to produce the flamethrower as Bill goes
to check the hole that Frank fell into
the control box for the electric fence
has been fused to speed limit signs it's
like how bill has taken everything and
repurposed it into something else but
important detail here notice four years
after setting up this fence The Vines
are starting to grow in the barbed wire
just a few years in and nature has
already started to make it difficult to
maintain security Bill checks to see if
Frank is infected how'd you get that
yeah a really good question that this
episode doesn't answer this is a federal
invention that they wouldn't have
invented until at least some time into
the pandemic meaning bill would have
either had to have killed the Thatcher
Soldier to do this or found it among
some dead Federal soldiers on some raid
Far Beyond Lincoln I think Bill might
have had to kill someone so Frank is
played by Murray Bartlett who you might
know as Armand the concierge from White
Lotus season one and Bill tells them if
I feed you then every bum you talk to
about it is going to show up here
looking for a free lunch
and this is not an Arby's well Arvest
didn't have free lunch was a restaurant
I think this hilarious response is the
moment that bill realizes Frank is smart
and he at least likes him now notice how
Frank runs his finger through the dust
on Bill's mantle discovering a purpose
for himself here in this home when Bill
enters with the meals his eyes
immediately darn over that mantle he's
acutely aware of the very first
different detail of this room that he's
entered every day for the past three
years and for the first time in this
pandemic he is feeling self-conscious
Bill serves Frank this amazing meal on
Fine China he uses Chargers a man who
knows to pair rabbit with a Beau Chile
I know I don't seem like the type
no you do yes Frank is letting Bill know
that he sees him and it's okay it's on
the piano Frank plays Linda ronstadt's
long long time but he plays too fast
maybe intentionally to bait bill into
playing it correctly I don't know I just
love this as a way of showing how Frank
moves fast he is Frank he gets right to
it whereas Bill wants to take things
slow both these men are Romantics just
moving at different speeds unfortunately
have been able to find each other here
at the end of the world and I think I'm
gonna lie
for a long long time
now the speaker of the song is tired of
everyone telling them that they'll find
love eventually and they just accept a
fate of loving someone who will never
love them back and having to live with
the wounds of heartbreak now it is 2007
in this scene but Massachusetts back in
September 2003 on outbreak day would
have been just two months before the
Massachusetts Supreme Court ruled that
the state was required to legalize
same-sex marriage leading Massachusetts
to become the first U.S state to
recognize gay marriage in the following
May in 2004. so on outbreak day bill was
right on the cusp of being able to live
closer to the way that he wanted to long
long time as a 1970s song performed by
Linda Ronstadt but the words were
written by Gary White whom Ronstadt saw
at a show in 1969 so going by Frank's
radio code this song was written by a
musician in the decade of the 60s the
60s decade meaning nothing is in but
when the song's words were paired with
and immortalized by just the right voice
that of Linda Ronstadt it became a 70s
song in the 70s decade means new stock
so Linda and Frank were the new stock we
actually learned latest episode the code
was Frank's idea oh and I had this idea
that we should uh we should use codes
for the radio in case anyone's listening
oh that's a good idea like I was
thinking like the decades like 80s
trouble look you guys The Last of Us
clearly a masterpiece but we gotta admit
it's pretty Grim so let's just take a
collective breather for a moment and
cleanse our mental palette with a little
snack break from boxu boxu is a premium
Japanese snack subscription that works
with family businesses all over Japan to
deliver a new theme of authentic
Japanese snacks every month beyond the
tasty treats each box suit comes with a
booklet that teaches you all about the
theme where the snacks come from and it
even teaches you a few Japanese words
and phrases your first boxes theme will
be Seasons of Japan and then after that
you'll get new themed boxes every month
like this one this month's theme is
shinshin New Year and we learned that
New Year's or shinshun is a festive and
food filled time in Japan families munch
on Toshi Koshi soba on New Year's Eve
visit shrines and even make Mochi and
I've made no secret how I love mochi
let's give it a try
I love Mochi that's just sweet it's just
so soft on my teeth oh man and the nice
thing about baksu is that when you
really fall in love with a snack like I
just did you can stock up on your
favorites through baksu Boutique both I
in the new Rockstar's office have been
receiving these boxes for ages we love
them and so if you want to try some of
these unique snacks with us and support
the channel just click that link in the
description and use code new rockstars
to get 15 off your order so after they
kiss Frank asks what's your name it's
just so sweet that Frank sheds a tear
here as this is such an emotional
catharsis for both these men neither of
them thought they'd ever have a chance
like this it's just great that he loves
his man so much despite not even knowing
his name because Bill never told him his
name so we jump cut from their sex too
oh [__] you come on yeah this is the
bill and Frank players of the game
expected as I said in the game Frank
gets sick of Bill's paranoia and leaves
him he actually tries to leave the town
of Lincoln but he gets swarmed by
infected he gets bitten and he hangs
himself leaving a suicide note for Bill
telling him that he'd rather be dead
than spend another day with him so since
they clearly had a lot of bad days in
the game it's good that we get to see at
least one bad day here they're fighting
because Frank wants to tidy up the whole
neighborhood so that they're not just
surviving they're actually living paying
attention to things
it's how we show love this is my street
too so let me love it the way I want to
remember Frank had Bill take a shower
before they made love and Frank will
repeat this definition of love to Bill
when they're old men do you love me
yes they love me the way I want you to
so they host this wonderful garden party
with Joel and Tess and now you can see
that their yard has been mowed and all
the surrounding houses have been painted
with flags raised it feels like a
regular neighborhood the two grunters of
the pair talk to each other I understand
if my uh
if mine brought strangers into our
situation I wouldn't be happy either
yeah it's so sad Joel never identified
what Tess was to him but even Bill
tracked that because this comes back
later now in the game Tess was the one
who kept contact with Bill and Frank
Joel never went to the town and he
didn't even meet Bill until Ellie was
with him Joel notices that the fence
needs repairing and he promises to hook
Bill up with some barbed wire last you
the rest of your life
lives yeah a little adjustment from Joel
indicating to Bill that he can see see
what he and Frank mean to each other in
case bill was trying to hide it and as
Frank says paying attention to things is
how we show love when the Raiders attack
at night Frank wakes up to see the
battle underway already bills didn't
want to wake up Frank because he didn't
want him to join him in the shootout one
wonders how many nights Bill might have
kept watch outside while Frank slept
Bill only gets shot when he turns around
to tell Frank to go back inside and he
gets hit in the lower back but bleeds
out the front meaning that was the exit
wound and there's no bullet to remove
fortunately time jumps ahead again to
the end of their lives in 2023 notice
the neighboring houses aren't as nice
anymore because both men are older
especially Frank who would have been one
of the two spending more time to clean
everything up and now he's in the
wheelchair we see Frank's paintings
including one of Joel and his brown
jacket and remember Bill and Frank's
first meal at the dining table had them
at opposite ends of the table but now
they sit right next to each other an
inverse is the famous marriage montage
and Citizen Kane where Kane and his wife
sit farther and farther away from each
other over time also in their bedroom
there's a lovely painting of Bill
adorning the wall on his side of the bed
but on the next morning there's a
momentarily scary jump cut to Bill
waking up with Frank out of focus in the
wheelchair in the background it reminds
us of Ms Adler back in the first episode
is Frank infected oh God oh God but no
no it's fine but this is Frank's biggest
fear to become too old and too frail to
stop the cordyceps from finding his way
to him Frank has terminal cancer now and
so he wants his leg to end and he says
I'm not gonna give you the every day was
a wonderful gift from God's speech I
have had a lot of bad days
I've had bad days with you until but
I've had more good days with you than
with anyone else yeah again I just love
this change that we get to see them grow
old together because it's not like in
the game you ever see this couple
together you're just seeing how the
relationship ended but this adaptation
invites us to imagine their mixed bag of
life together as half full instead of
half empty which is important we need
reasons to root for Humanity's Survival
on this show their final Sunset includes
a shot of the whole where Bill first
found Frank followed by that strawberry
plant from that really happy memory they
exchange wedding rings by the piano
where they share their first kiss and
Bill recreates the first meal they ever
cooked for them grilled rabbit the same
exact label abujillet he even rotates
the plate the same way on the charger as
he did before in the very first meal
they had now we don't seem open the
second bottle at the end of the meal
showing how bill has already drugged it
so that he will die too Bill tells Frank
this isn't a tragic suicide at the end
of the play I'm old
I'm satisfied
and you were my purpose now the tragic
suicide at the end of the play is not a
Romeo and Juliet reference Craig Mason
is actually paying homage to Mark
Crowley's 1968 play the boys in the band
which has a very similar line it's meant
to dispel The Stereotype that all gay
love stories have to end in tragic
suicides that plays titles actually not
to A Star is Born which of course is
another suicide ending and they got the
title from the scene where James Mason
tells Judy Garland you're singing for
yourself in the bar is in the back and
if Bill Wheels him off to bed the
candles stay lit when Joel and Ellie
arrive a few weeks later he notice how
that wax has melted down meaning those
candles continue to burn the interior
lights all remain on as well because
obviously they didn't ever turn them off
also dust is collected on the Civil War
the house reverting back to its Dusty
State as it was when Frank first ran his
finger along that mantle now Joel tries
to get into their bedroom but the breeze
slams the front door shut distracting
him and stopping him from forcing his
way in some force was keeping Joel from
disturbing the grave accidentally but we
later learned that force was Bill having
left the window open that's what caused
the air pressure in the the house to
cause this draft to go through and pull
the door shut to keep the grave a sacred
place in his letter bill has left Joel
with some parting wisdom and it's read
by Ellie I used to hate the world and I
was happy when everyone died but I was
wrong
because there was one person worth
saving that's why men like you and me
are here
we have a job to do yeah Ellie stops
before reading the end but Joel grabs
the letter and if you look closely you
can see what he wrote use them to keep
tests safe and if you and she decide you
something I recommend pairing something
yeah he's ending this letter by saying
he hopes Joel and Tess could finally
confess their love to each other and
Bill left him with a wine pairing option
like what he used to woo Frank it's so
sad now we learned that the reason that
80s music played was because it was
automatically set to if it wasn't reset
in a few weeks and Ellie finds the gun
that Frank kept in his writing desk I
wonder if this is a gun that bill wasn't
even aware of Ellie wears this red shirt
now this is the same red shirt that
Ellie is most often seen wearing in part
one of the game and I like how with this
and the gun She carries she is in a way
symbolically activated as a sort of
playable character or at least at some
point in the future will be playable
Joel has to teach Ellie what a seat belt
is because this is a girl who's Blown
Away by the concept of airplanes so yeah
a working truck must be like a spaceship
to her and Ellie plays a cassette of
Linda ronstadt's long long time which is
how we close the app episode as the
camera Retreats back through bill in
Frank's open bedroom window from their
body's perspective as they watch them go
now this shot of the open window with
the breeze brushing the curtains was
actually an intentional nod to the menu
screen of the game the press any button
screen and the producer is actually
considered opening every episode with an
open window where HBO Max users could
press play on a different window every
episode to begin it they ended up
scrapping that idea but we get that
concept here with Frank's painting a
bill on the wall right above some dead
flowers and I just love that we leave
Bill and Frank with the window open so
their souls are free to go had these two
men not found each other they both would
have died alone in the darkness
underground like that underground
infected that Ellie stabs this episode
corpses overtaken by the fungus without
Souls Frank would have been in the pit
bill would have been in his bunker where
the only window was
Windows 2000 and so while this series as
a whole is a statement of Love's
destructive power indeed it did lead
bill to make Frank's suicide a double
suicide there remains an undeniable
Beauty to that destructive love and the
love that bill was able to feel for
Frank was so powerful that it inspires
Joel to save Ellie hey a reminder to
subscribe to the Deep dive and follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]